Euskal Herria Bildu cumple con su palabra
y con el mandato de las urnas.
No especularemos en este momento histórico.
Frenar a ultraderecha
es 1 mandato democrático
de la amplia mayoría del Pueblo Vasco
con el que tenemos absoluta responsabilidad
y determinación,
porque frenar a las derechas reaccionarias
es condición indispensable e innecesaria
para abrir 1 nueva legislatura.
La nueva legislatura
debe servir para
profundizar en la implantación de los derechos sociales
y económicos de los y las trabajadoras,
la consolidación de políticas que fomenten la Paz
y la convivencia
y la apertura,
por fin, de 1 debate en torno a la plurinacionalidad
y del del estado
y de los derechos nacionales de nuestro Pueblo.
Somos partidarios de aprovechar esta oportunidad.
Estas son las cuestiones
que trasladamos a Pedro Sánchez
en la reunión del viernes,
en la que mostramos
nuevamente nuestra disposición para seguir colaborando,
a la vez que le pedimos al Presidente
del estado español funciones,
ambición
y valentía para abordar los aspectos pendientes
que quedaron de la pasada legislatura.
Estas serán las líneas de trabajo
que guiarán nuestra actividad
en el congreso y en el senado